president biden is imposing new
sanctions on the cuban regime after the
violent crackdown on anti-government
protesters earlier this month
the move comes as some boaters in
florida plan to launch a flotilla of
private vessels
toward cuba this morning manuela jorquez
is in miami
manny good morning what are they
planning exactly
good morning their plan to have dozens
of boaters join in haven't quite
materialized at least not just yet but
the vote
voters who are here at this marina say
they plan to head to key west check in
with the coast guard and then sail
towards cuba where they will show their
support with fireworks and
chinese lanterns many have shown their
support for protesters in cuba on the
waters off miami
but now organizers of the flotilla say
they'll head to 15 nautical miles from
havana
which would be international waters as
they make a show of support for the
cuban people
captain adam shammy with the u.s coast
guard says it's legal
but crossing into cuban waters is not
and can incur fines and prison time
there's also the weather what might seem
like it's pretty safe waters just a few
miles from shore
when you're 50 miles from shore can look
very differently
the planned trip comes as the biden
administration announced
new sanctions on alvaro lopez miera the
cuban minister of defense
as well as the cuban interior ministry
special brigade
for repressing the pro-democracy
protests in cuba that began july 11th
there are reports of possibly hundreds
detained since the protests
in a statement president biden said the
cuban people have the same right to
freedom of expression
and peaceful assembly as all people
miami mayor francis juarez argues cuba
is not a priority of the biden
administration the cuban people
are defending themselves with rocks and
sticks against
guns and clubs and so i've even called
for things as dramatic as
not taking off the table the possibility
of some level of military intervention
jorge duani is the director of the cuban
research institute at florida
international university
he says the biden administration is
trying to find the middle ground between
the more open policies of the obama
administration
and former president trump's swift
reversal much of the calculus
regarding what to do next with cuba has
to do with
next year's midterm election here in
florida and i'm sure that's part of the
discussion
within the white house
duwani also says the biden
administration stated goal of restoring
internet service to the island which was
cut off by the communist regime
after the uprisings there may be the
best way to help protesters keep the
momentum
going gail all right manny thank you
very much